lot of things to talk about today
today the president will host an event
with business leaders and bipartisan
governors including governor whitmer and
governor holcomb to call on congress to
quickly pass competitiveness legislation
like the bipartisan innovation act
during the event the president secretary
raimondo and the participants will focus
in particular on why passing
competitiveness legislation is critical
for lowering prices for working families
on essentials like cars and household
appliances by addressing bottlenecks
like semiconductor chips manufacturing
more in america and strengthening our
supply chains to make our economy more
productive as we've seen over the past
year global events like the pandemic or
russia's unprovoked aggression in
ukraine can result in disruptions to
global supply chains that lead to higher
prices for american consumers which is
further underscores the importance of
strengthening our economy and making it
more resilient to shocks like that in
the future also wanted to note that
today the president signed an executive
order outlining the first ever whole of
government approach to addressing the
risks
and harnessing the potential benefits of
digital assets previously there has been
never been an organized effort to bring
together the expertise and authorities
of the entire u.s government to inform a
holistic approach to digital assets with
this executive order the president is
calling on experts across the federal
government to assess and develop policy
recommendations that address the
implications of growing digital assets
sect of the growing digital asset sector
across consumer protection financial
stability national security and climate
risk
when we finally say i heard there was a
little kerfuffle in here after the
briefing the other day i just want to
say uh that what we're going to do today
is we're going to try to start with the
third and fourth row and fifth and sixth
row get more people's questions answered
we are always happy to answer questions
from here i could go on for hours just
sit in your seats but we also know you
all have a lot on your plates so what we
try to do for everybody's knowledge is
balance between all the things reporters
and all of you have focused on and
trying to be informative in this
briefing room but we also are here uh as
people have followed questions so with
that josh let me have you start okay
i know the pool's supposed to gather
around 1 45 yes that's too long so one
easy question
um the u.s declined to help facilitate
transfer of jets to ukraine yesterday
does the us want the ukraine to get jets
how urgent of priority is that
so let me give you an update on the
status uh as of now uh the secretary
austin chairman millie
and members of our defense department
are in touch with ukrainian counterparts
nato counterparts disgusting discussing
what are clearly logistical challenges
here and i would note josh that in the
statement put out by my colleague
at the pentagon yesterday he made clear
that obviously the proposal from
yesterday that fighter jets manned by
americans departing a nato base to fly
into airspace contest contested with
russia raises serious concerns for the
united states and nato so the logistical
questions here just to put a little fine
point on it are things like how do you
get planes into ukraine in a way that is
not escalatory
and what are the logistics and
operational details of that those are
conversations are happening between
counterparts at the military level and i
would expect any update might come from
them okay let's go around michael why
don't you kick us off
uh sure
two questions on venezuela yeah
so obviously yesterday two americans
were freed uh and uh they are now home
uh nicholas maduro has agreed to
re-engage in the mexico city talks so is
the ball in the president's court at
this point to continue the engagement
and what is the plan
well first uh the the let me note that
the return of two american citizens is
certainly uh welcome news exciting news
and it would not have have happened uh
without the tireless work over the
series a series of months uh by a number
of our diplomats including of course uh
our uh special envoy for hostage affairs
roger carstens
who worked on this for months over the
course of time
you know we are we'll continue to
discuss a range of issues
including
first and foremost
americans unjustly held unfortunately
they are not the only individuals held
there the individuals who return
so that will be something that we will
look to have ongoing discussions about
i'd also note that maduro said he will
resume talks with venezuela's interim
president in mexico so that is an
encouraging
sign so there are a range of issues
discussed on this trip uh there are a
range of issues to discuss uh moving
forward uh but right now we're just
celebrating the return of two americans
okay and just to follow up are there
concrete plans for uh continued
engagement for another round of talks
and
is there
uh you know you mentioned i think on
monday
that energy security was
part of the conversation what can
venezuela contribute to
energy security
well i don't have anything to preview
for you in terms of additional talks or
rounds of talks but again uh we are we
are very pleased to have these two
americans returned home
we if there are opportunities to
continue to discuss that that's
something we are open to uh there are
obviously ongoing concerns about the
health and well-being of of anyone
detained whether it's there or in
venezuela or russia afghanistan syria
china iran and elsewhere those are
conversations we are always going to
want to engage in
obviously it is facts factual you all
know that venezuela is a large producer
of oil but in terms of any decisions or
discussions or where that may go from
here i have no nothing to preview or
predict for you on that front nadia go
ahead thank you um many american
companies
declared yesterday that they're shutting
down in russia including visa
[Music]
mcdonald's etc the russians said that
they're going to confiscate their assets
there
how would the white house react to that
i know they're all private companies but
basically declaring that they're going
to nationalize these assets according to
the russians and second not exactly
related um
do you there are some reports indicating
that russia is delaying the signing of
the iran agreement and remain the
negotiation in vienna from taking place
for their own interests because they
don't want
obviously all to be released
to make up for the shortage
well let me take the second one first i
would say that
our team we're continuing to engage with
iran deal partners including russia on
iran nuclear negotiations we believe
russia shares a common interest in
ensuring iran
never acquires a nuclear weapon in our
view there's nothing uh that should be
required of or will be offered from the
united states as it relates to russia's
sanctions that is related to uh their
invasion of ukraine uh but again we
believe we share an objective here
always in the final stages there are
details to be worked through and we will
continue to work through those
in terms of your first question on the
seizing i think it was on the potential
seizing of
private sector assets in russia
for for companies that have decided to
pull back and pull out
of the country
obviously we have not well we have
applauded the actions of a number of
companies that is not something we have
uh been pushing from behind the scenes
if that makes sense
if they were to take those actions i'm
certain there would be steps we would
take but nothing has happened at this
point in time so let me talk to our
economic team and see if there's
anything more we can predict for you um
go ahead
thanks jen i have two questions uh first
about the florida bill that just passed
uh restricting the uh speaking about of
homosexuality and gender identity after
third grade and then i have a question
about surveillance matters that have
been in the news um regarding the
florida bill um in 1994 when many of us
in this room were in school
president biden actually voted for a
much broader restriction
that banned federal funds from being
used for quote the promotion of
homosexuality as a positive lifestyle
alternative
why did he do that and can you describe
how his thinking has evolved over the
years well i think that you have seen
the president speak passionately about
his view
that a bill like this
a bill that would
discriminate against families against
kids
put these kids in a position of not
getting the support they need
at a time where that's exactly what they
need is discriminatory it's a form of
bullying it is horrific i mean the
president has spoken to that in terms of
his views and comments from 25 years ago
i think the most important question now
is why are florida leaders deciding they
need to discriminate against kids who
are members of the lgbtqi community what
prompts them to do that is it meanness
is it wanting to make kids have more
difficult times in school in their
communities i would pose that question
to them and we can talk about it more
tomorrow if you get an answer was there
a reason you supported the same policy
though in in the 90s when we roll into
school
i think what's important to note here is
how outspoken the president has been
against discrimination against uh kids
against members of the lgbtqi plus
community and what we're looking at here
is a bill that would propagate
misinformed hateful policies and impact
children so that's the question i hope
maybe you can pose that uh to some of
the leaders in florida maybe they'll
return your phone calls and i'll look
forward to having that conversation
well perhaps chris could call up
afterwards but i i'd like to ask about
the surveillance matters as well
um
senators wyden and heinrich who are
democrats recently alleged that the cia
is conducting a mass surveillance
program that implicates american data
and that it's outside of the statutory
bounds that people think it's within um
first could you say anything about that
to reassure americans regarding their
data and secondly uh according to a
recent court filing by special counsel
durham uh there was a technology
executive who was quote uh mining the
executive office of the president's dns
traffic and other data um uh cisa the
federal agency for cyber security uh
said in a 2020 document that dns data
can be sensitive and that's important to
secure um there are competing narratives
of course about what data was actually
implicated so could you share with us
what data was implicated in in this and
whether the white house any has any
security or privacy concerns regarding
this alleged review i i have nothing
further to comment on your questions
obviously this is a
an investigation i put you in the
department of justice members of
congress obviously we have serious uh
respect for people's privacy in the
country go ahead
um a quick follow-up you mentioned the
logistical challenges about flying
planes to ukraine through contested
airspace
why can't the united states put those
planes on trains or automobiles um i
guess
are we really to believe that when we're
sending or preparing to send billions in
aid uh that you know
this is the logistical bottleneck that
is stopping us from getting them those
points well it is a serious logistical
bottleneck right obviously there's
there's obvious concerns that department
of defense has spoken to about flying
planes from u.s air bases right uh that
they spoke to yesterday uh these planes
uh you
carting them down the street i think is
not as easy as you may think it is um
planes if they have to be taken apart
and put back together you have to have
people who are able to put those planes
back together uh you have to ensure that
there's uh they can be safely moved uh
through the course of a contested uh
country or not you know a country where
there uh is a war going on uh with the
uh with the russians uh
you know who implemented that war so
there are a range of logistical
operational challenges those are
important conversations to happen
between military experts and our defense
department
leaders and officials secretary austin
chairman millie and their counterparts
and then should we expect that the u.s
export import bank is going to continue
to underwrite loans uh that would
support commerce with russian companies
and corporations given the uh the charge
of sanctions that we've seen against i
would have to check and see how the
sanctions are implemented obviously
we're going to abide by all of our our
own sanctions um and we've tried to
implement them as quickly as possible
but i can see if there's any specific
impact on them go ahead so john kirby's
line is that from transferring the
planes the latest iteration was not
tenable now you say it is what's not
tenable the uh the arming of the
ukrainians with jet fighters or is
what's was it merely the logistical
things you're speaking to i think uh the
defense department spoke uh primarily to
this and they were very specific jeff
they said fighter jets manned by
americans departing a nato base to fly
into airspace contested with russia
raises serious concerns for the united
states and for the nato alliance we have
provided a billion dollars in military
assistance i would say the the 350
billion that was announced just less
than two weeks ago i believe the defense
department has conveyed almost all of
that has been delivered we have not held
back on providing weapons anti-missile
systems tank systems at all at any point
in this process but there are important
operational logistics concerns here uh
and steps uh conversations that should
happen between military experts and
that's exactly what's happening
it's a policy that the white house would
support or like to find a way to solve
again we're having discussions about it
but there are operational logistical
questions that are important ones that
uh we will leave to our defense
department colleagues
there's another round of arrests in
russians like estimated at 5 000 over
the weekend
is the
protesting the war what is the
assessment of the white house as far as
how this has all affected regime
stability
well
i would say that
you know i don't think we assess that
president putin thought that there would
be such an outpouring of objection in
his own country
he would probably not have cut off
access to media access to social media
access to basic information for the
people of his country
if that were the case
so we have seen people across russia
bravely courageously protest speak out
against a war that they believe uh is
unjust is unwarranted um and uh you know
that is incredibly powerful now
unfortunately as you know and many of
you know for work from working for these
networks uh and news organizations there
have been tough decisions that news
organizations have had to make whether
about whether they're going to keep a
presence in russia uh because of the
restrictions and it's not just uh you
know it's not just the the speaking out
of president putin it's about uh fines
it's about the threat of arrest it's
about safety and security that
organizations have to consider so
in terms of stability i don't have any
assessment for that other than to tell
you that uh it's pretty clear he didn't
bet on the opposition from within his
own country why don't you go in the back
thank you um
one if i could follow up on the earlier
questions about the jet side is this a
difference
of kind or a difference of degree i mean
is the objection that it's a
it's an airplane or because as you point
out we're sending them
things that destroy tanks things that
shoot down airplanes so i mean
if it can be done without uh
i don't i mean they would know where
they came from and so i don't even see
there's any positive deniability or
anything like that what is the hang-ups
exactly
i think it's pretty clear it doesn't
require a military expert to understand
why having planes
fly from a u.s air base into a contested
uh
part of the country where there is a war
is not in our interests and not in nato
interests so there are logistical and
operational challenges to consider and
discuss uh it isn't that easy to move
military planes around maybe not as easy
as some of you may suspect it is um and
those are conversations again that are
happening between military experts and i
would point you to the department of
defense for the status of that broadly
um is there any concern that making the
lives of average russians miserable you
know with all these companies pulling
out and things that are designed to hurt
the economy as opposed to putin
personally as opposed to his oligarchs
personally is there a worry that that's
going to consolidate his support within
the country rather than make
rather than diminishing
well i would say that our view and the
view of our global partners is that uh
when a president like president putin uh
you know launches an uh a war of choice
where he is brutally
killing uh injuring people in a
sovereign country there have to be
consequences those consequences are
economic and significant no question
about it our our target is not to hurt
the russian people um
it is to squeeze president putin and the
leadership around him
but
what the impact is is certainly
having a devastating impact on the
russian economy and uh our view is that
over the over the medium and long term
that uh that is not going to be
sustainable for president putin and uh
the team around him go ahead
so um i'm certainly here the
administration talked about uh gas
prices the way to speed up the lowering
gas prices is speed up the transition to
those clean energy um gas prices have
risen month over month every month since
president's been in office so is the
feeling then from the president that the
american people just have to wait till
2030 when the president has set his goal
for zero emissions or half cars being
sold with zero emissions
no
that's never been our theory or our
belief
i would say that since president putin
began his military buildup on ukrainian
borders the price of gas at the pump in
america has gone up 75 cents which is
significant of course there is
widespread consensus that the sharp
run-up of energy prices since january
was called by caused by the building of
putin's troops at ukraine's border the
reality as we know is that russia is the
world's third largest oil producer and
energy supply disruptions and market
volatility are result of his aggression
don't you don't take my word for that
there have been a number of assessments
back in january uh federal chair uh fed
chair powell warned that there was a
risk to our economy based on quote
what's going on in eastern europe in
early february jp morgan analysts
projected that disruptions of oil flows
from russia could push oil prices to 120
per barrel which is what has happened
our approach has always been two-fold
one we need to ensure the supply meets
the demand out there in the marketplace
there's a couple of ways to do that
obviously we're engaging with big global
oil producers around the world to meet
that demand but there are also as we've
talked about a few times in here 9 000
unused oil leases that oil companies
could certainly tap into and we've
encouraged them to do that so that's
certainly a way to address the price of
gas on february 14th was at a high
highest level since 2014 so it was
already at an elevated level
and the build-up of troops was even
before that
i want to ask you about tomorrow we're
going to get a cpi inflation number
that's expected to be pretty big um it's
supposed to rise from the 7.5 that was
month over month so gas prices are part
of that i want to know what specifically
the administration has done they've been
working on that has worked to bring down
inflation
well i would say
first because well we don't have the
data at this point yet but as we're
looking ahead we certainly assess that
um that we expect to see a high headline
uh and head headline inflation in
tomorrow's february inflation data a key
reason as you touched on our energy
prices we've seen the price of gas
increase as i noted 75 since the
beginning of the year as putin built up
his military near ukraine and took
increasingly aggressive measures that
were felt in the markets we also expect
some increases in pandemic affected
sectors given our strong recovery from
omicron in february that's a positive
sign for our economy and for americans
who are going out again traveling going
to restaurants and getting back to
normal and we also expect to see
continued moderation in used uh car
prices so that's what our prediction our
assessment is at this point in time in
terms of steps and we have taken to
address inflation
what is what is work so october 13th is
when you announce the port initiative
yeah um what specifically can you point
to that has worked to bring down
inflation well there are a number of
steps we've taken if you've seen if you
compare month to month we've seen
inflationary pressure or inflationary
numbers go down month to month even as
we looked at the year to year numbers go
up which we entirely predicted
one we've taken
steps to address bottlenecks in the
supply chain to reduce those bottlenecks
those are steps we've taken not just
since october but since earlier this
year there's no question that we've seen
impacts as it relates to
getting goods and supplies out to the
american public
we've also taken
steps to address what we see as
shortages and issues in the
semiconductor
space we i just opened this briefing by
pressing for the passing
of the competitiveness of legislation
that the president would love to sign
into law because we know that one of the
big pressures is of course
from the uh car
and manufacturing uh sector the car
sector um and then third we know that
because of um the the pressures on the
energy sector that that has been an area
where we've continued to see have an
impact on inflationary pressure we
believe in the last few months
that has been because of president
putin's invasion of ukraine but as i've
noted there are a number of steps
working to address that why don't you go
ahead and yellow thank you
well there is uh is there an assessment
by the white house
for the
losses on the russian side like
financial
economy losses because every time a new
or fresh wave of sanctions is imposed uh
the response from moscow would be it was
expected um so is there like an
assessment of the losses
as a result of all the sanctions that
have been imposed and also another
question on um eu as you know president
zielinski asked for an accelerated um
push to join eu and eu leaders or i
think representatives are meeting today
in brussels
does the white house um support um uh
ukraine
in eu
um the last question that's really up to
the eu and ukraine to determine together
on the on the first question i i don't
think that's what they're saying anymore
uh they have had their stock market has
been closed for days the ruble's worth a
penny uh they're headed toward what many
outside economists have described as a a
recession uh they uh have had a huge
strain on their financial markets and
systems uh so i don't think the facts
bear out uh if that is the claim anyone
is making and i have not seen that claim
be made much less okay go ahead in the
middle
thanks jen uh does the white house
believe there's an opportunity to
convince china to play an effective role
in resolving the crisis in ukraine
well here's what we've seen
china do to date um we have seen
um them speak out at the munich security
conference or have a public comment i
should say about the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of ukraine
we've seen them
abstain from u.n security council votes
we've seen them largely abide
by the sanctions
that have been put in place i would note
though that if any country tries to
evade or work around our economic
measures
they will experience the consequences of
those actions so
our assessment right now is that they're
abiding by the requirements
that have been put in place but
we would continue to encourage any
country to think uh a lot about what
place they want to uh what role they
want to play in history as we all look
back okay let me go to the front go
ahead
thank you a couple questions on the
future leadership of uh nato what is the
white house speaking on against merc
stepping down in just a few months as
the
leader of the alliance
well i think that nato uh
has not been more united uh in the last
several months uh in decades um and well
no one wanted that to be prompted by
the invasion of a dictator like
president putin into a foreign country
that
unity
among nato partners and the strength of
that unity is certainly something that
has been a direct impact of his
aggression in terms of future leadership
obviously that would be for nato
partners uh to determine uh but we uh
certainly uh recognize and value uh the
leadership that has been displayed by uh
nato leaders and the alliance over the
course of the last few months follow up
on that uh um
have you
as a nato member ruled out asking
stockholmer to continue in this time of
the biggest crisis in world war ii i
don't have anything to predict for you
in terms of the future of nato
leadership from here
the search for a new leader of nato
again it's up to nato leaders and
partners to determine that i don't i'm
not a spokesperson for the nato alliance
so i would certainly uh point you to
them to speak to that in any further
detail go ahead welcome back to
venezuela if they can because if you
hear you're probably going to not be
able or just not answer but okay
go for it let's gustavo carnavas and
jorge alberto fernandez do we know why
they were released
i don't have any more details on that i
can provide us officials who were part
of that delegation are they all back
from venezuela
i believe yes
i will confirm that for you though
should we
anticipate the imminent release of any
other americans who are being held there
right now well as you know um as we are
working on
bringing any unjustly detained americans
home from any country in the world
whether it's venezuela russia
afghanistan syria china iran and
elsewhere we typically don't discuss
that because it puts at risk the
potential for bringing individuals home
but yes we would still we are still
going to work on bringing others home
who have who did not return on the plane
last night the high-ranking member of
juan guayno's team told the miami herald
this week quote it is foolish
to think that maduro will quit russia
when a great deal of the corruption
funds have been deposited in russia and
when russia furthermore is its greatest
ally this is a mistake to buy oil from
maduro is the same as buying oil from
poop two things i think i know where
you'll go on the first one but i want to
give you the opportunity to respond if
the united stand so much time together
ed i appreciate it if the united states
recognizes waido as the leader of
venezuela
why did the u.s feel it necessary to
negotiate with the maduro regime
and was the guido team made aware of the
plans for u.s officials to go to
venezuela to meet with the maduro
government before they went
on the last i just don't have anything
more to convey to you about private
diplomatic conversations i would note
that one of the steps that was announced
uh yesterday was maduro saying he was
willing to resume talks
with venezuela's interim president
certainly we would note that
and obviously we part of our effort here
as you now know was related to the
health and well-being of american
citizens detained
in venezuela hence we had discussions
with those who were detaining them
because there were so many questions
good ones about
the planes
going from poland to ukraine and whether
it would be the interlocutor on sunday
when the secretary of state was asked
about this possibility of a plane swap
he said quote that gets a green light
and we're working with poland and
possibly backfilling their military
equipment what changed between him
saying that on sunday
and torrey newland and others yesterday
in the pentagon saying actually that's
not terrible i don't think that's
exactly how i would see how the events
transpired i believe that tony secretary
blinken was asked about uh poland's
giving planes to the ukrainians that's
certainly a choice they make as a
sovereign country we've never opposed
that never stood in the way of that we
still do not today what we're talking
about here though is the proposal
yesterday as you know was for these
planes to fly from a u.s air base in
germany and we have understandable
concerns about that so what we're
talking about now through military
channels is the operational uh concerns
uh how this could work the logistics of
it um and
and those conversations are ongoing
go ahead thank you why did you guys
decide to rebrand the rise and gas
prices as the
putin price hike
i mean if you want to use that on fox i
welcome that but i think it'll get a lot
of air time because we have heard the
president warn for months the gas prices
were rising because of the supply chain
and because of closed pandemic demand
if you guys knew for months that this
was going to be the hashtag putin price
hike why are we just hearing that now
well peter if we go back to six months
ago i don't think anybody was predicting
we would be exactly where we are as it
relates to russia and ukraine as you
know that events in the world including
the invasion by russia of a foreign
country does prompt instability and
volatility in the global oil markets and
there are all sorts of different issues
that can impact that that's what we're
seeing now outside economists and
analysts have conveyed and said publicly
that russia's invasion russia's buildup
of troops president putin's decision to
do that very early this year led to a
lot of the instability and volatility in
the oil markets you don't have to take
my word for it so therefore if president
putin's buildup of military troops is
leading to volatility and an increase in
oil and prices hence you have a putin
pump gas price pump okay you're right
you and the president are both talking
thank you
spit that out
you and the president are both talking
about producing energy here saying that
oil and gas companies have 9 000 permits
to drill now they could be drilling
right now would present biden cut red
tape
to make that possible
what red tape needs to be cut when they
have the permits uh they have the
capacity to do it
what's holding them up does president
biden think that each of these 9 000
leases that are available have oil or
gas in them because industry experts are
saying that
that accusation is is a complete red
pairing some permits are viable and some
are not but when you say that
this represents a fundamental
misunderstanding as to how this process
works
well first of all the
nearly 60 percent of leased acres remain
non-producing that's a lot uh in the
range of 20 million acres so there are 9
000 uh unused approved permits to drill
in they should not require that should
not require us inviting them to do that
they should do that themselves the
additional permits so would the
president what additional permits do
they need there's no they have the
leases are there the permits are there i
don't think they need an embroidered
invitation to drill that is their oil
companies what is that what is happening
what has happened but what is the
permits have been granted peter what is
what is happening here is that we are
seeing these are private sector
companies we recognize that many of them
are making record profits we see that
that is all publicly available data they
have pressure to return cash to
investors and their shareholders what
we're saying right now is there is a war
we're asking them to to go uh use the
the approved permits use the unused
space and go uh get more supply out of
the ground in our own country okay and
then just a quick yes or no because
there's a lot of gray area here it is a
restart of the keystone xl construction
completely off the table as long as joe
biden is president well why don't you
tell me what that would help address
i'm asking you if it is an option you
guys say all options are on the table is
restarting keystone construction one of
them if we're trying to bring about more
supply that does not address any problem
it's supplied from canada a friendly
ally instead of saudi arabia that's
already that's we're already getting
that oil peter it's the the pipeline is
just a delivery mechanism it is not an
oil field so it does not provide more
supply into the system it does not
adjust stable is it possible that joe
biden will ever
say
you guys can go ahead with construction
of keystone xl there's no plans for that
and it would not address any of the
problems we're having currently go ahead
and we're going to have to wrap up soon
we'll try to make quinn can you help us
understand what exactly would have
transpired for the polish government to
publicly
propose this idea of getting the
fighters to ukraine that the u.s would
then publicly reject was there at any
point a breakdown in communication
between the two countries well i think
as uh our under secretary of state
torrey newland testified yesterday we
were not made aware of their plans to
make that announcement yesterday so i
wouldn't call that a breakdown and uh i
guess it's a temporary breakdown in in
in communication but we have a strong
and abiding relationship with poland the
president spoke with uh president duda
just last friday obviously the vice
president is on her way there not not
related to this particular issue which
will be worked through military channels
uh but it was more about the mechanism
for how it would be delivered and that
is the issue that is operational and
we're still discussing safe to say that
the u.s was caught off guard by the
initial announcement from the polish i
think we said that yesterday
on gas prices quickly
the president said yesterday i'm going
to do everything i can to minimize
putin's price hike here at home and then
hours later as he was getting off air
force one he said i can't do much about
that right now can't do much right now
that was the exact support from the
president for anyone that might have
been confused seeing the two statements
from the president within a couple of
hours what would be your explanation
does the president believe there is
action that he can take to address gas
prices or does he believe there's not
much that can be done well i i would say
that the the short gaggles when the when
the president is getting off the plane
and getting into a car are not always
super comprehensive as i think many of
you have experienced
they're not always extensive but what
the president
said yesterday in his lengthy remarks
before his trip and what we have said
many times is that there are a range of
steps that we will continue to take
including coordinating uh with the
global community about ensuring the
supply in the marketplace meets the
demand that includes the release from
the strategic petroleum reserve uh that
he announced a second one just a few
weeks ago that includes continuing to
work and coordinate with global oil
suppliers around the world something
that his national security team and he
is engaged in
in a nearly daily basis and that
includes considering a range of domestic
options but the oil markets
oil markets are global right and it is
all about meeting the supply
demands that are out there and clearly
given the invasion and given the impact
of that we need to look at a range of
options but we've already taken a number
of steps and we will continue to and he
said that all yesterday morning and the
same day go ahead okay i got this may
have to be the last one i'm sorry go
ahead on the military plane yeah the
vice president you said that what's
going on now are logistical discussions
with military officials so this issue is
not a priority it's not going to be part
of the vice president's discussions i
would expect it's going to happen
through military channels those
conversations have been ongoing and i
would expect they would continue to
happen through those channels
not as central part of the vice
president's discussion i'm never going
to say it's not a priority but i would
just say that the appropriate channels
for it because they're about the
operational movement of military
equipment are through military channels
i know we're gonna have to wrap up in a
minute here because you guys have to go
to the event just a quick reaction to
the russian air strikes reportedly um
striking a children's hospital in the
ukrainian city of mario pool
i i we have certainly seen those reports
um and as a mother i know a number of
you are mothers yourself it is
horrifying to see the type of um the
barbaric use of military um force um to
go after innocent civilians in a
sovereign country um and you know i know
we've seen the reports on all that you
have all been broadcasting over the last
couple of hours uh unfortunately i don't
have more details than that at this
point in time
you all have to go to an event with the
president yes go ahead recognize one way
though
venezuela because i think that was a
direct question from ed
that we had that's how we were we have
referred to him yes no no but you didn't
say it tells you what's recognized
thanks everyone so much